[Musique]
je suis profondément ému
vous savez il ya deux ans j'ai rencontré
trois ans kim ont impacté qui m'ont
boosté dans ma défense pour l'humanité
et la nature
il s'agit en fait de nicolas hulot le
récent ministre écologiste français qui
a préfacé mon dernier livre sur le
climat il s'agit de l'actuel ministre
écologiste belge de la wallonie vous
savez en wallonie nous avons les
flamands qui sont des anglophones et les
wallons qui sont des francophones
l'actuel ministre écologiste walo
s'appelle carlo di antonio qui m'a
boosté lorsque je fus en belgique en
tant que bénéficiaire d'une bourse
d'excellence de l'académie belge
il m'a invité à participer en tant que
les jeunes toi je noir au parlement
développement durable de la wallonie il
m'a boosté parce que je me suis rendu
compte qu'en fait la priorité des pays
du nord c'est l'alimentation durable
nous sommes en pleine guerre vous savez
ce qui manque ont boosté
c'est la rencontre est de gains député
de grand parlementaire européen
quand vous connaissez tous il s'appelle
josé ovi mon activisme se fonde en fait
j'ai trois grands hommes qui ont changé
ma vie
aujourd'hui je parlerai fils aïtor la
guerre silencieuse et les armes
invisible nous sommes aujourd'hui à une
ère une ère géologique que nous appelons
anthropocène seiler géologique dédié un
homme en fait nicolas hulot a eu à
démontrer
à la vingt deuxième conférence n'est pas
ti sur le climat que l'avenir de
l'humanité dépend de nous l'homme qui
est au centre en fait de la
dénaturalisation des milieux naturels
l'homme quitté garde l'environnement se
retrouvent aujourd'hui confortée à
l'extermination de sa destinée vous
savez il ya un physicien russe qu'on
appelle vladmir bednarski qui
aujourd'hui est au coeur de cette
anthropocène l'anthropocène peuple
relative est tenace qui depuis les
années 1800 était démontré comme effet
boostant ce qu'on appelle la los faire
avant de partir aujourd'hui
vous devez savoir ce qu'on appelle la
noce faire la noce faire c'est tout
simplement la serre de l'intelligence
humaine
l'homme à la quête du gain facile
l'homme du fait de l'industrialisation
l'homme du fait des sociétés
capitalistes qui sont aujourd'hui en
fête au coeur l'économie qu'on appelle
l'économie linéaire une économie qui
n'étaient pas en fait que du capitalisme
une économie qui ne produit que de la
richesse mais qui ne valorise pas et qui
ne préserve pas l'humanité et la nature
vous savez mes chers amis l'avenir de
l'humanité pas réellement de chacun de
nous non qu'ils sont ici présents nous
devenons des missionnaires démissionner
de la nature et de l'humanité il est
vrai lors de ma présentation je suis un
weygand le vega c'est celui là qui
aujourd'hui est supérieur un végétarien
le vega pour porter des chaussures ne
portera pas des chaussures en cuir me
portera des chaussures en cuir
synthétique
fabriquer donc artificiellement le vigan
lui il ne consommera pas de la viande le
végal ne consommera pas du poisson
le vega ne consommera pas du lait de
vache
le vega ne consommera donc pas du
fromage qui dérivent du lait de vache en
fait le v go au delà du fait qu'il ait
levé jettent à rien parce que le
végétarien lui par exemple
lato végétarien ne consommera pas de la
viande mais consommera quand même du
lait voyez le aux végétariens qui
consommera de la viande qui ne
consommera pas de la viande plus tôt
mais consommera du lait des oeufs
vous savez le vélo lui malgré le fait
qu'ils s'étaient dits la viande le
poisson les oeufs et toutes les variétés
parce que cela menace les animaux vous
savez il s'était dit vraiment de porter
de ceinture en cuir vous êtes surpris
aujourd'hui que je me suis habillé aussi
simplement possible
mes chers amis le vigan c'est un fou le
vega c'est celui là qui respecte le
bien-être animal
cette année il est voté une loi en
belgique pour préserver le bien-être
animal en wallonie j'ai contribué vous
savez quand je parlais du ministre carlo
di antonio à l'élaboration de la loi ou
interdit le glyphosate en wallonie lors
de ce parlement développement durable
depuis janvier 2019 il interdit en
wallonie en belgique
le glyphosate le roundup de monsanto à
la suite donc de ce parlement la léchère
amine sommes en pleine guerre une guerre
microbiologiques nos cellules vous savez
nos tissus nous organes sont en pleine
guerre
c'est pour cela que notre système de
défense immunitaire que sont les
polynucléaires les macrophages qui vont
capter internaliser phagocyter digérer
des gradés présentés les molécules
étrangères 1
vous savez sont en pleine guerre par
ce que nous ne cessons de pour lui et
notre organisme
nous ne cessons de consommer des
aliments toxiques des aliments qui sont
nocifs pour notre santé les pesticides
qui aujourd'hui en pleine guerre ont lu
tous nos cours d'eau vous savez les
réseaux trophiques on appelle encore la
chaîne alimentaire les réseaux
trophiques c'est l'ensemble donc de tout
ce que nous pouvons manger vous voyez
dans la nature il ya les végétaux qu'on
appelle encore l'est autotrophes
aujourd'hui vous devez savoir que
l'autre off c'est un être vivant capable
de transformer lui même le carbone
minéral en carbone organique l'homme
carnivores et en un été où trophe va
consommer ce qu'à vannes déjà transformé
par les végétaux grâce au foot au
phénomène de la photo ces thèses l'homme
caniveau aujourd'hui à dépasser la
limite même sur un carnivore
vous savez il ya un mot que j'ai inventé
qu'on appelle à zéro ce faire on a parlé
tout à l'heure de l'anthropocène nous
avons dépassé l'anthropocène qu'ils
aient l'air géologique dédié à l'homme
nous sommes aujourd'hui à une ère que
moi j'appelle azito ce faire
l'être humain carnivore qui massacrent
le bien-être animal n'a plus peur du
sang humain
toutes les sociétés humaines qui
respecte le bien-être animal ont
respecté le bien-être des humains
alors je nous invite chacun à tous a
désormais pente et de prix à respecter
le bien être des animaux ainsi désormais
nous allons respecter les hommes nous
allons respecter nous mêmes et nous
allons respecter l'humanité et la nature
soyez des messagers
[Musique]